in this country nasa is getting ready
for another attempt to launch its
artemis mission to the moon tomorrow
after technical problems delayed
monday's liftoff mark straussman is at
the space center mark you know we were
all ready we were all in our places
bright shiny faces ready to see it take
off on monday how's it looking for
tomorrow
looks uh maybe even brighter and shinier
gail at least the weather uh certainly
looks good and let's hope the second
time is is the charm for nasa here the
latest from
mission control is that they are a go
for launch but that said that's not a
guarantee that this rocket behind me is
going to get off the ground nearly 500
of what they call
launch commit criteria all have to line
up for this rocket to get a lift off and
that did not happen obviously earlier uh
this week stormy weather a host of
technical troubles all derailed nasa's
launch attempt on monday the biggest
problem an issue with chilling one of
the four core stage engines down to a
super cold
minus 420 degrees fahrenheit now nasa
believes a faulty sensor was actually to
blame and if that happened again then
ignore it during tomorrow's countdown
the weather forecast a 60 chance for go
now local officials are expecting
something to change over the weekend
because we're heading into this holiday
weekend they're expecting as many as 200
000 people to show up hoping to get a
glimpse of the liftoff
tony
all right i'm hoping it lifts off myself
mark thank you very much